the bad news vampires live among us the
good news they're just as bored as the
rest of us even though they can live
forever
that's the concept behind what we do in
the shadows which has gone from
unassuming short film to cult movie to
successful tv show
before what we do in the shadows arrived
on tv it was a movie that premiered at
the sundance film festival in 2014
but its origins go back even further
than that in 2005 new zealand-based
filmmakers taika waititi and jermaine
clement wrote directed and played the
main characters in a 27 minute
mockumentary short film called what we
do in the shadows
interviews with some vampires it didn't
get much traction so why tt and clement
moved on to other projects
for ytt that meant directing the
oscar-nominated short film two cars one
night
and the feature-length movies eagle vs
shark and boy
he also directed a few episodes of
flight of the conchords the hbo show
about a wannabe folk rock duo co-created
by and co-starring clement
about four years after they made the
short the duo got to work writing the
feature version it then took another
four years after that to get the
production off the ground
editing proved to be the most
time-consuming of all their tasks as the
film's 87-minute running time was the
result of carefully winnowing down 125
hours of footage
the vampires of what we do in the
shadows are not the typical brooding and
frightening creatures of the night
they certainly try to be romantic and
mysterious but they just can't get the
hang of it
thiago as played by waititi is awfully
cheery for someone who kills people
while vladislav is played by clement
hides his pining for an old girlfriend
by trying to be as dramatic as possible
both actors pulled from various sources
to flesh out their characters
waititi based viago's sunny and
effervescent disposition on his own
mother's personality
as for that silly way he speaks that
came from a stranger
as he told empire magazine he's partly
this guy i once met while i was
traveling a german guy who just had a
very high pitched voice
that man's name was philip but
apparently he preferred to be called mr
happy
as for vlad clement based him on a
classic bloodsucker none other than
count dracula himself
specifically gary oldman's portrayal of
the famous vampire in the 1992 film bram
stoker's dracula
every work of vampire fiction has its
own particular rules there are certain
tropes that show up frequently such as
how vampires don't appear in mirrors and
can die if they're exposed to sun
when the creators of what we do in the
shadows devised the rules for their
universe
instead of making up a whole new mythos
they chose to adopt what was established
by the great granddaddy of them all bram
stoker's 1897 novel dracula
so much vampire culture stems from that
influential book
such as the creature's aversion to
crucifixes as taika waititi explained to
empire
i think that era was where the rules
came from that they can transform into
bats and so on
we've gone for the movie dracula dracula
it's also important to note that what we
do in the shadows takes place in a world
where other prominent fictional vampires
exist
and that sometimes influences the
character's behavior for example in the
tv show
nandor buys glitter so that he may
sparkle like edward cullen does in
twilight
i'm going to sprinkle it on my face and
on my body
like twilight and nandor's familiar
guillermo speaks of his desire to become
a vampire after watching an interview
with a vampire and becoming enamored of
antonio banderas character armond
when ytt and clement adapted what we do
in the shadows for tv
they switched the setting from new
zealand to staten island this called for
a cast of all new characters including
colin robinson the franchise's first
american vampire and its first energy
vampire this is a creature who feeds not
on blood but on the psychic and mental
energy of others by boring them half to
death with dull conversation
in 2019 clement told the hollywood
reporter it's a term i've heard used to
describe people who are difficult to
talk to and i've definitely been
cornered by these people at parties
those people that you feel you need to
be saved from and the longer you're in
the conversation the more difficult it
is to get away
it was just taking that to the
supernatural level mark proch the actor
who plays colin robinson improvises most
of his torturous dronies
according to clement a lot of it's not
on the page he can just do that
endlessly he's such a funny guy but i do
wonder how this is going to affect
parties for it now i just wait for
the comments to come in hey can you
mansplain
any louder yeah sure both the film and
tv versions of what we do in the shadows
utilize the same catchy opening theme
song
it's mildly spooky and with its crisp
folk influenced british invasion sound
and relative obscurity it would also
feel at home on the soundtrack of a wes
anderson movie the song is called
appropriately enough you're dead
the film's editor tom eagles amassed a
collection of tunes about death
and then he turned ytt and clement onto
your dead they eventually decided to use
it to score the opening montage of old
photographs and drawings
to get permission the production team
had to track down the woman who wrote
and performed it in 1966
american folk artist norma tanega the
singer who died in 2019
is a one hit wonder in the u.s but not
for you're dead
her only charting song was the equally
odd yet charming walk in my cat named
dog which hit number 22 on the billboard
hot 100 in 1966.
it took a while for what we do in the
shadows to make its way to tv
the film was released in 2014 and
although taika ytt and jermaine clement
almost immediately entertained offers to
turn it into a show it didn't premiere
on fx until march 2019.
that's mostly because ytt went on to
become an in-demand filmmaker
he directed the 2017 marvel cinematic
universe entry thor ragnarok and
followed that up with the world war ii
comedy jojo rabbit
in short he had a lot on his plate and
he could easily put off even thinking
about making a tv version of what we do
in the shadows which she's admitted that
he and clement didn't really want to do
as he told vulture in 2019 we didn't
mind the idea of it existing but the
idea of us doing it was just a lot of
work
we don't like work while he's an
executive producer on the series and has
directed a few episodes he's mostly left
it in clement's hands
that wasn't exactly a surprising
decision as the pilot was ordered right
when he was offered thor
as he put it to vulture i couldn't see
anyway that i could be totally involved
in the show and the film so i made
jamaine do it
it was great for me to come and just as
a director and all the scripts were
great they're really
very funny in fact probably better that
i didn't write on it
with its seventh episode entitled the
trial what we do in the shadows really
stepped up its game
after the ancient vampire baron dies on
their watch the main characters must go
before a council of
empires who were all played by actors
who had previously portrayed
bloodsuckers on other shows and movies
the guest stars included buffy the
vampire slayers paul rubins true bloods
evan rachel wood
from dust hill dawns danny trejo only
lovers left the lives till the swinton
and blade himself wesley snipes
additionally jermaine clement taika
waititi and jonathan broth all reprised
their roles from the movie
all the continents gathered here
together
on staten
clemente ytt were interested in having
cameos on the show but they couldn't
figure out a reason to make it happen
that was until clement remembered that
he'd met swinton at the south by
southwest film festival when both were
presenting their respective vampire
movies
he recalled to entertainment weekly she
said do something where our vampire
characters are together i'll just lock
that away in my brain
while the tribunal turned out great
there were some actors who couldn't make
it
kiefer sutherland of the lost boys
turned it down while true blood's
alexander skarsgard was filming in
australia
cate blanchett also missed out she
reportedly really wanted to appear
until ytt realized she'd been put on the
list of fictional vampires by mistake
as she'd never actually played a
bloodsucker the long-form structure of
tv's what we do in the shadows provides
an opportunity for writers to really
explore what daily life is like for an
ageless being
and it turns out that the answer to that
question is that it's boring and
monotonous
with that in mind the show's biggest
influence is something other than
supernatural
horror showrunner paul sims explained
this inspiration to the hollywood
reporter
the office was about the tdm of working
in an office and nothing really ever
changes or when something changes it
quickly goes back to being tedious
in this show it's sort of like take that
and multiply it by hanging out with the
same people for 200 years and being sick
of each other
one of the main sources of comedy on
what we do in the shadows is how
pathetic it is that the vampires have
completely squandered the gift of being
granted an infinite time on earth
as sims put it part of what's funny
about the show is that these vampires
had 200 years during which they could
have done anything they wanted
they could have learned any language
written a thousand books become
proficient in any musical instrument
and all they've really done is sat
around and bickered with each other
while what we do in the shadows takes
place on staten island it actually films
in toronto the sprawling abode where the
vampire roommates live is something of a
noted house of force
or at least the one where the first
season was shot is before the show's
production moved in it was used to film
the big screen version of stephen king's
hit
the second season had to be shot in a
different house though due to a last
minute production emergency
as paul sims recounted to the hollywood
reporter right before we got to toronto
to start shooting again we were told we
couldn't use the vampire house that we'd
been using
that was our biggest production struggle
the crew ultimately had to build a new
exterior to match the original house
and then they began to get ambitious as
they added on a larger topiary garden
and a koi pond in the parking lot of the
sound stage where interior scenes were
shot
so it sounds like it all worked out in
the end in the sublimely silly season 2
episode on the run laszlo assumes a new
identity while hiding in pennsylvania is
a regular human bartender named jackie
daytona
he disguises himself with just a pair of
jeans and a toothpick
he's trying to avoid jim the vampire to
whom he owes an old debt
how did you know my name
it's printed on your card very clearly
jim is played by mark hamill who got the
role because he's a huge what we do in
the shadows fan
he enjoyed the movie but didn't think
the show would be great because taka
white tt and jermaine clement weren't in
it but he found himself proven wrong
as he told vulture i always get nervous
about shows i like
because i find something i really love
and it gets cancelled so i tweeted about
it several times trying to get my
followers to give it a try
apparently that's what put me on their
radar and the next thing i know they
asked me to come on their show
hamill assumed that he would be given
just a small role a civil servant or a
neighbor perhaps
but when he was offered jim the vampire
he flipped out with excitement his guest
appearance ultimately helped elevate the
show's profile
on the run even earned an emmy
nomination for outstanding writing for a
comedy series and the show itself got a
nod for outstanding comedy series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you